outiller les cheveux du pneu le teint de
pêche et les petits pi 2 po sur une
cuisse de dieu ce poupon est en fait une
poupée un faux bébé naissant appelé
ribbon d'or les bébés reborn se vend une
centaine de dollars et peuvent atteindre
le millier selon les spécifications la
qualité d'exécution et la réputation de
l'artisan certains fabricants offrent
même l'option d'une fausse respiration
ou d'infos battements de coeur ces
poupées attire des femmes d'âge mûr des
collectionneurs mais aussi des femmes en
mal d'enfant ou endeuillées
on les surnomme déry bonnement mise
certaines d'entre elles n'hésitent pas à
trimballer leur poupon lors de sorties
ou à imaginer les scénarios de la vie
quotidienne comme des changements de
couches ou l'heure du biberon
le phénomène est moins marginal qu'on
pourrait le croire
la communauté de reborn est
impressionnant les sites de vente en
ligne et les groupes de discussion se
comptent par centaines des les photos
partagées sur les réseaux sociaux par
son thème 2010
[Musique]